bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission économique qui s'invite jusque
dans vos chambres
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de la chute de la natalité
mongeau astel bonjour olivier bonjour à
tous bienvenue dans ces caches la crise
ducobu 19 a eu de nombreuses
répercussions sur nos économies mais
qu'en est-il côté démographie
alors que certains s'attendaient à un
baby boom il semblerait que la france se
dirige tout droit vers ce que l'on
appelle un baby crash quel est l'état
des lieux de la natalité dans l'hexagone
et plus généralement en europe quelles
conséquences pourrait avoir ce fameux
baby crache sur nos économies
on va en parler dans cette émission et
pour cela en deuxième partie nous serons
en liaison avec l'essayiste antoine
bueno
mais d'abord quelles conséquences a eu à
la crise sanitaire et les différents
confinement sur la natalité en france
éléments de réponse avec le tiroir cash
d'antoine basse si on a souvent évoqué
les conséquences économiques de la
pandémie ou les conséquences
psychologiques du confinement
en voilà une qu'on n'avait pas forcément
vu venir bah oui des populations
confinées chez elles
on aurait pu penser que ça augmenterait
la tendance à faire des enfants
et bien c'est tout l'un verse on a
assisté durant ces derniers mois' qu'on
qualifie de véritable baby crash en
janvier 2021 en france on a vu 13 % de
naissance en moins par rapport à janvier
2020 la chute de la natalité la plus
importante depuis la fin du baby boom
dans les années 70 autres chiffres en
2027 135 mille naissances
le chiffre le plus bas depuis la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale et ce n'est
pas qu'en france puisque en espagne
c'est pareil en italie le pays se
dépeuple carrément et aurait perdu 400
mille habitants en 2020 et si ce
vieillissement des populations en
occident venait à continuer cela
pourrait mener à une catastrophe
économique
forcément au système des retraites mais
pas que certains secteurs pourraient
être fortement touché le secteur de la
petite enfance l'alimentaire
l'immobilier car les familles déménagent
principalement lorsqu'avec s'agrandisse
reste à savoir maintenant si cette
tendance va se confirmer ou si certains
attendent juste des jours meilleurs pour
faire des bébés
olivier ce bébé crash est-il passagers
ou est il amené à durer selon vous non
je pense qu'il est amené à durer c'est
que c'était une tendance qui a été
accélérée par le cos vide mais qui
n'était pas c'est pas nouveau
donc ceux qui s'attendaient à ce que il
ya une reprise à cause du confinement en
sont pour leurs frais encore une fois
mais dès 2008 vous aviez eu un plongeon
dans la démographie surtout en espagne
en italie aussi et donc qu'on voit très
bien que les crises font que les gens
ont moins envie de faire des bébés et de
laisser un enfant se dépatouiller dans
le monde actuel donc je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui est durable et est
quelque chose qui on voit depuis un bon
moment on est tous passé je vous le
rappelle en dessous des 2 10 ce qui est
le taux de remplacement si vous voulez
taux de fécondité minimum et on est tous
en dessous avec des catastrophes en
espagne en espagne c'est le plus bas
taux on est aujourd'hui autour de 1,20
1,24 exactement vous avez vous avez en
plus eu un plongeon on a eu les chiffres
de janvier février mars
il ya eu un plongeon de 20 % des
naissances donc on sait que le chiffre
de fin d'année sera catastrophique en
espagne en italie vous l'avais dit dans
le tiroir cache le la population baisse
et donc qu'on a un vrai souci alors ça
va jouer sur le potentiel de croissance
des pays de tous les pays qui sont
concernés et ça va jouer aussi sur la
dépendance c'est-à-dire sur le système
sur les systèmes sociaux de retraite et
autres qui
sont basées sur le nombre de personnes
qui travaillent par rapport au nombre de
sept personnes qui touchent de l'argent
donc ça va ça va être un vrai sujet
sujet qui n'est je vous le rassure
encore une fois jamais abordé par les
politiques parce que c'est trop
compliqué et c'est fatigant de
travailler merci olivier tout de suite
la deuxième partie de ses missions et
cette semaine pour parler à démographie
nous sommes en liaison avec antoine
bueno essayiste et auteur notamment de
permis de procréer aux éditions albin
michel bonjour antoine bueno merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
bonjour merci à vous alors antoine buéno
on l'a vu à la crise sanitaire est
arrivé certains espéraient un baby-boom
un boom de la natalité pour autant elle
les chiffres de l'insee à démontre le
contraire exemple avec janvier 2021 les
démographes de l'insee ont recensé 53
1900 essence et 13 % de moins qu'en
janvier 2020 alors est-ce un phénomène
exceptionnel ou est-ce qu'à chaque fois
que les populations finalement sont
confrontés à une crise la natalité
baisse de toute façon alors c'est très
intéressant parce que comme vous l'avez
souligné dans la première partie de
votre émission c'est complètement contre
intuitif qu'on aurait pu imaginer que
des populations qui sont confinées chez
elles et qui n'ont rien d'autre à faire
que faire des enfants s'en donnent à
coeur joie
donc là les chiffres que vous donnez
sont assez étonnants et étonnant parce
que si on les met en perspective avec
l'ensemble des effets de cette crise
sanitaire on s'aperçoit que la crise de
la corrida était un amplificateur de
toutes les tendances de toutes les très
grandes tendances qui préexistait qui
lui préexistaient qui gouvernait au
devenir des sociétés mais que cette
crise n'a fait que les reprendre pour
les démultiplier
je me suis amusé à parler de corona
vortex dire que c'est comme si avec la
crise de la cabine on était entré dans
un vortex c'est-à-dire un accélérateur
temporel et que tout ce qui était déjà
en germe
évidemment la mutation technologique
numérique la mutation de la gouvernance
des sociétés vers plus de technocratie
les mutations géopolitiques avec le
passage de relais de des états unis à la
chine
et on pourrait donner d'autres exemples
et là vous en donner un autre qui était
contre intuitif c'est celui de
l'évolution démographique du
vieillissement de la population
mais tout ça a été accéléré y compris
cette question démographique c'est quand
même passionnant et et à ses
interlocuteurs vous me passez
l'expression
alors maintenant la question que vous
voulez traiter sait quelles en sont les
conséquences parce que bien évidemment
ça n'est pas nouveau et c'est un
phénomène qui est pointée alors j'ai vu
le petit coup de patte d'olivier aux
politiques effectivement il n'en parle
pas des masses quoique dernièrement
françois bayrou
le haut commissaire au plan est relancé
la polémique du vieillissement de la
population
donc c'est quand même un serpent de mer
c'est à dire que alfred sauvy dans les
années 50 alors qu'on était en pleine
explosion démographique et qu on était à
la veille de la naissance du mouvement
écologique qui allait se construire sur
la peur de la bombe p la bombe p pour
bomber population donc le mouvement
écologique allait se construire là
dessus et lui alfred sauvy disait
exactement inverse il tirait la sonnette
d'alarmé en disant attention on va vers
un hiver démographique il ya plusieurs
expressions qui sont devenus consacré
comme ça en occident dans les pays
développés ça va être une catastrophe
parce que nous allons avoir de moins en
moins de jeunes et nos économies ne vont
pas pouvoir tenir là dessus alors il
faut bien comprendre que ce phénomène du
vieillissement d'abord il ya deux effet
kiss cool ainsi encore une fois vous me
passez l'expression le premier effet
c'est celui du vieillissement
le second effet qui arrivent plus tard
parce qu'il ya un effet d'inertie 1 ça
prend du temps c'est celui de la
diminution de la population
tout à l'heure dans rapport à portée de
votre émission vous avez cité le cas de
l'italie qui va perdre des habitants
mais pour que la plupart des pays
perdent des habitants
il va falloir d'abord que leurs
populations vieillissent beaucoup et
donc ça prendra pas mal de temps il ya
des pays qui à la fin du 21e siècle vont
perdre beaucoup d'habitants mais c'est
quand même à la fin du 21e siècle
donc ce phénomène de vieillissement de
la population il est à la fois
inéluctable est universel il faut bien
voir ça inéluctable parce que c'est la
conséquence de ce qu'on appelle la
transition démographique la transition
démographique ça s'est produit
dans toutes les populations qui ont
connu un développement économique à
partir de la révolution industrielle
donc il ya aucune exception pour
l'instant c'est donc le passage avec le
développement économique d'un état de
forte natalité est forte mortalité
ça c'est les sociétés traditionnelles a1
et a2 faible natalité est faible
mortalité est donc entré les deux entre
les deux vous avez un décalage serre que
les naissances continue entre les deux
d'être importante alors que le taux de
mortalité baisse en chute libre
et c'est pour ça que vous avez une
explosion démographique dans tous les
pays qui sont en transition
olivier en 2018 la france avait le taux
de fécondité le plus élevé de l'union
européenne avec 1,88 enfants par femme
une crise retarde on l'a dit relais
projet de parentalité pour autant 2018
c'était aussi à la troisième année
consécutive de baisse de la natalité
c'est donc un phénomène de fond comment
l'expliquez concrètement ce phénomène
oui notre invité vient de nous en parler
c'est c'est le le développement et puis
c'est aussi le l'état crise c'est ce que
je vous disais en 2008 on a assisté déjà
un
avec la crise économique on a assisté à
une baisse de la natalité donc ce
n'était pas une surprise
alors on n'était pas confinée en 2008 je
vous la corde mais
il n'empêche que les gens ont peur les
gens ont peur les gens ont moins
d'argent donc évidemment ils font moins
d'enfants et donc c'est un phénomène
qu'on connaît par exemple qui est très
avancé au japon au japon y perdent de la
population tous les ans vous êtes à
aujourd'hui autour de ça 126 millions un
petit peu en dessous de 126 millions de
japonais vous serait selon les calculs
en 2050 en dessous de 90 millions donc
ça veut dire qu'ils vont perdre un tiers
de leur population
ce qui est quand même beaucoup et ce qui
va avoir des conséquences énormes en
termes économiques
alors le japon qui est en récession
permanente depuis vingt ans mais surtout
une hutte des impacts sur l'immobilier
des impacts sur les évidemment sur les
systèmes de retraite et des impacts sur
tout tout le tout dépend d'économie
entier vous savez alors c'est toujours
la même blague mais vous savez qu'au
japon on vend plus de couches on les
vieux que de couches pour les bébés donc
que vous avez un système économique qui
qui fonctionne pas du tout de la même
façon que dans un pays dans l'est dans
lequel la population est jeune
vous n'avez pas les mêmes habitudes de
consommation et ça va se ressentir sur
je vous dis la croissance potentielle la
croissance potentielle d'un de en france
c'est en gros 1 % voilà et donc imaginez
si on poursuit les courbe de
vieillissement
on va tomber en dessous de 1% et alors
là tous les petits plans nos politiques
actuelles vont s'avérer un peu en l'air
donc comme d'habitude vous me direz ça
va pas changer grand chose mais là je
pense que avec un vieillissement de la
population qui va s'accélérer
du fait de cette crise eh bien nous
allons avoir des surprises sur le
potentiel de croissance que monsieur
bruno le maire continue à nous annoncer
à aa + 2 4 % ou à plus de 5%
je pense que ça va être compliqué
antoine buéno la baisse de la natalité
on l'a vu en c'est un phénomène qui tout
ce qui touche pardon à la france mais
aussi à l'union européenne en 2010 neuf
le nombre moyen d'enfants par femme
était de 1,53 sur le continent au delà
de lui on va jeter un oeil aux
prévisions de l'onu sur la population
mondiale en 2050 nous serons 9,1
milliards d'habitants 6 6 milliards en
2100 et enfin 3 milliards en 2002 sans
la baisse de la note la baisse de la
natalité c'est donc un phénomène qui
globalement va toucher l'humanité tout
entière
alors je suis pas d'accord avec certains
de vos chiffres parce que les prévisions
de l'onu sont triples c'est à dire que
l'onu donne toujours une prévision
moyenne une prévision ôter une prévision
basse alors pour la prévision vous avez
donné à 2050
on est d'accord mais pour la prévision
vous avez donné à 2100 6,6 vous avez
pris sans doute pour illustrer votre
propos
la prévision basse alors que la
prévision haute elle est à plus de 11 2
milliards jusqu'ici
depuis les années 50 c'est la prévision
médiane qui s'est toujours réalisés
alors vous me direz ça peut changer
demain
oui ça c'est possible et d'ailleurs on
n'a pas de boule de cristal pour savoir
si demain il y aura pas une rupture mais
enfin si on se fie à ce que l'onu a
toujours réussi à faire depuis les
années 50 c'est la prévision médiane
qu'il faut prendre en compte
une précision qui est d'ailleurs
hallucinante parce qu'en 1950 l'onu
avait prévu qu'on serait 6 milliards
d'habitants en l'an 2000 et le six
milliardième humain est né en octobre 99
ça que j'aurais plutôt tendance à me
fier à 11,2 milliards en 2100 mais ça
change rien au fond du problème c'est ce
que vous avez dit de toute façon c'est
un phénomène qui va toucher toute la
planète
le véritable problème c'est que ça va
pas toucher toute la planète au même
moment
autrement dit plus on est un pays
développé plus on est avancé dans la
transition démographique plus on va
prendre ce mur de plein fouet et olivier
donner quelques quelques chiffres tout à
l'heure moi j'en ai un qui me frappe
énormément c'est pour la chine
la chine va perdre en 2100 alors c'est
pareil vous me direz 2100 c'est loin
mais enfin quand même le chiffre mérite
d'être retenue 400 millions de chinois
on n'a jamais vu un tel
ur démographique dans l'histoire
d'aucune population dans toute
l'humanité 400 millions de chinois en
moins en 2100 alors olivier l'a dit en
fait si on résume il c'est un phénomène
qui à la fois structurelle et
conjoncturelle structurelle parce que
concrètement quand on est dans un pays
développés on a envie de faire autre
chose que faire des enfants et c'est
très lié au statut de la femme est
conjoncturelle parce que bien sûr plus
on a peur de l'avenir moi on a envie de
faire d'enfant ceci dit moi
personnellement je vois cette détente
dénatalité surtout dans les pays
développés plutôt d'un bon oeil pour ça
que je fait frémir les économistes qui
dès par ailleurs ont tout à fait raison
de frémir lors je la voit d'un bon oeil
cette chute de la natalité parce que
d'un point de vue environnemental d'un
point de vue écologique à l'instant y
c'est à dire au moment où on parle c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle
autrement dit dans les pays développés
on est de très gros émetteurs de gaz à
effet de serre tant qu'on n'arrive pas à
décarbonés notre mode de production
avoir moins d'enfants
c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour la
planète en revanche si on arrive à
passer à une économie véritablement
durable qui soit neutre en carbone
alors là on pourra recommencer à avoir
des enfants ça posera plus problème mais
dans l'immédiat
comme il ya sept cette inertie cette
difficulté à passer à un système
décarbonée j'ai un enfant de moi ça veut
dire que j'ai un gros émetteurs de gaz à
effet de serre en moins c'est la raison
pour laquelle moi je suis pas favorable
à la planche à billets démographique
pareil c'est une expression mais ça veut
dire à relancer essayer de relancer la
natalité
d'autant plus que comme on l'a dit c'est
pas facile de relancer la natalité parce
que c'est lié à des chats des causes
sociologiques culturelles psychologique
très profonde
autrement dit si demain vous
démultiplier les allocations familiales
les places en crèche et cetera il ya
très peu de chances que vous augmentiez
considérablement le nombre de naissances
en france il ya une sorte d'asymétrie
dans les politiques
de démographique vous pouvez déprimer
encore plus le taux de natalité si vous
réduisez le nombre de crèches ou si vous
supprimez les allocations familiales ou
quotient familial etc
ça vous pouvez encore largement le
déprimé en revanche c'est très difficile
de faire repartir à la hausse les
naissances et il ya de nombreux pays qui
s'y sont essayés par exemple l'iran dans
la période récente qui avait mené une
politique de nataliste et puis ensuite
il ya plus réussi à faire repartir les
choses la chine est un excellent exemple
actuellement alors en train de venir on
va revenir sur vos propos ce sera juste
après la pub bienvenue dans ces caches
si vous nous rejoignez au sommaire cette
semaine on parle elle démographie avec
la france qui se dirige vers un baby
cracher pour en parler nous sommes en
liaison avec les céistes antoine bueno
alors qu'antoine diot vous êtes dans un
cadre différent nous avons eu un
problème technique mais à tout va bien
maintenant alors je voudrais qu'on
revienne sur vos propos précédents
antoine bono en tenant compte des enjeux
environnementaux et écologiques et ce
qu'il faut agir selon vous pour inverser
la tendance
alors compte tenu des difficultés qu'on
a à décarbonés nos modes de production
moi je vois la dénatalité des pays
occidentaux plutôt d'un bon oeil
je m'explique si on pouvait agir sur
l'économie comme sur un simple levier
qui nous permettraient du jour au
lendemain de décarbonés l'ensemble de
nos activités
on pourrait avoir des enfants augmenter
le nombre d'enfants sans que ça pose de
problème mais comme ce n'est pas le cas
et que la cette transition la cie tenté
qu'on n'y arrive pas ce que bien sûr
c'est pas du tout un acquis mais si tant
est qu'on y arrive
elle prendra des décennies dans
l'immédiat avoir un enfant ça veut dire
avoir mettre au monde à nouveau gros
producteur de gaz à effet de serre et
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous avez
des études nombreuses qui ont été faites
assez régulièrement depuis dix à vingt
ans qui montre que parmi les gestes
environnementaux qu'un individu peut
avoir renoncé à avoir un enfant est de
loin le geste le plus impactant devant
arrêter de rouler en hummer ou arrêter
d'utiliser les avions ou deux
irv et gagnent donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi je suis pas favorable à une
relance de la natalité
mais par ailleurs la question se pose de
savoir si on peut relancer la natalité
c'est dire si c'est facile là encore
comme avec un interrupteur de faire plus
d'enfants et l'expérience prouve que
c'est pas le cas parce qu'on l'a dit
tout à l'heure
cette chute du taux de fécondité elle
est liée à des évolutions structurelles
des évolutions de fond des sociétés et
donc revenir en arrière et un certain
nombre de pays qui s'y sont essayés et
on n'y arrive pas ça se heurte à cette
mutation des mentalités et des modes de
vie
olivier une réaction cette analyse alors
il ya quand même un petit bémol la
russie s'y étaient essayés avec une
prime à la maternité qui étaient
importantes
avec ensuite une une
dz et
pendant 18 mois je crois donc qui
représentait une partie importante du
salaire moyen
et ça avait plutôt bien marché ça avait
plutôt bien marché apparemment ils ont
abandonné 7 7
cette stratégie parce que aussi manque
de manque de sous pour le faire et
instantanément la natalité quand même
retombé donc on peut le faire alors
alors sur ce point là il faut vraiment
qu'on se rencontre avec olivier parce
qu'on allait les mêmes démarches
intellectuelles j'ai cru aussi que la
russie serait un contre exemple
et il se trouve que selon les
démographes et en particulier une étude
de l'ined qui est très récente
même ça même là ça n'a pas été le cas
parce qu'il y aurait une sorte d'effet
d'aubaine
c'est à dire que les familles qui de
toute façon avait l'intention de faire
un enfant l'aurait fait plus tôt pour
bénéficier de ces aides là mais cet
écosystème favorable n'aurait pas
convaincu les familles qui ne voulait
pas faire d'enfants de toutes façons
franchir le pas parce que évidemment il
faut bien voir que avoir un enfant c'est
une question de choix de vie quoi et ça
implique tellement de choses que les
gouvernements sont quelque part des
armées on ne fait pas ou très rarement
des enfants pour des allocations
familiales ou des places en crèche
alors justement olivier un mot sur les
déclarations de françois bayrou c'était
le 16 mai dernier
le haut commissaire au plan a plaidé
pour un pacte national pour la
démographie le pays doit selon lui avoir
plus d'enfants sur l'immigration il
s'est aussi dit favorable à des apports
elle limitée ou en tout régulé et
réfléchi il recommande donc de renouer
avec une ambition démographique
notamment avec une politique familiale
ambitieux c'est quoi une politique
familiale ambitieuse olive et c'est
justement ce dont on parlait mais ça ne
s'est visiblement ça n'est pas ça n'est
pas convaincant le le le
le problème va être pas simplement
économiques 1 le problème va être
géopolitique parce que vous avez d'ici
vous aurez le seul continent qui va
continuer à croître c'est l'afrique avec
un milliard de plus un individu qui est
qui pose déjà depuis un bon moment des
soucis 2 d'immigration etc
ça va s'amplifier forcément puisque avec
un milliard de plus d'individus et un
gâteau qui ne va pas forcément augmenter
dans les mêmes proportions un gâteau
économique 1 il est assez clair que il
va ça va poser un problème qui est déjà
là je vous dis mais qui va s'amplifier
et il alla ce qu'ont voulu faire
certains gouvernements comme celui de
madame merkel qui a été de dinde
importer un million de
oui plusieurs plusieurs même millions
d'individus et
de d'afrique vers l'allemagne on a bien
vu que ça ne marchait pas économiquement
et que c'était à c'était une catastrophe
économique parce qu'il n'arrivait pas à
les intégrer
comment on redonne aux gens l'envié de
faire des enfants je sais pas faim je
sais pas comment on l'est on les incite
à faire des enfants
le le problème c'est que vous pouvez pas
quand vous avez des gens qui est
aujourd'hui avec raison quand vous avez
des gens qui ont peur de l'avenir qu'ils
ont peur de ce qui est en train de se
passer
qui ont des difficultés déjà à vivre
tout seul et qui se disent que ça va
être encore plus compliqué avec un
enfant à part améliorer la situation
économique et de et de 2,2 vie je ne
vois pas très bien ce qu'on peut faire
c'est en effet pas en leur ponctualité
leur finançant balle que ça va changer
la face la face des choses donc surtout
quand vous faites un enfant a priori
c'est pour plus que 18 mois ou 12 mois
donc vous le vous l'avez à l'élever
jusque jusque tard de cocker et tous les
messages donc c'est pas à fond un apport
ponctuel d'argent qui va changer la face
du monde
si vous permettez sur cette question et
olivier l'a souligné en fait il ya deux
problématiques premièrement est-ce qu'on
peut relancer cette natalité très
compliqué on l'a bien dit est ce qu'on
doit le relent de la relancer pour des
raisons environnementales
moi je dis non mais je voudrais être
très clair dans mon propos ce que je
veux te dire c'est que il y a deux
véritables problèmes serre que quand je
dis que pour des raisons
environnementales il faut pas faire plus
d'enfants ça veut pas dire que je
néglige la question du vieillissement de
la population ce que je veux dire c'est
que il ya un problème qui est un enjeu
vital on a besoin pour vivre d'un
écosystème
alors que d'un autre côté on a une
véritable problématique mais qui est un
enjeu pas vital mais le dirait politique
économique sociale donc on peut pas
vivre sans écosystèmes mais on peut
peut-être vivre avec des retraites plus
petit est par ailleurs si on ne peut pas
relancer la natalité
il ya d'autres leviers il ya d'autres
moyens d'action qui sont peut-être pas
la panacée mais qui existe alors olivier
a parlé tout à l'heure de l'immigration
bien sur l'immigration est un levier et
ça inévitablement on y recourt rats mais
il n'ya pas que ça il ya aussi la
technologie
il faut pas oublier que cette évolution
démographique 20 s'inscrire dans
l'évolution globale d'un monde qui va
plus ressembler à grand chose de ce que
nous connaissons
du fait de cette révolution
technologique qui est en cours et de la
crise environnementale parallèle quand
je parle de la crise environnementale
mais à l'instant on évoqué l'afrique
moi je sais pas du tout ce que vont
devenir les africains en 2050 pour une
raison très simple c'est que la même si
on arrête du jour au lendemain d'émettre
des gaz à effet de serre les
températures vont remonter d'ici à 2050
disait entre 2050 et 2080 entre 2 et 3
degrés de plus par rapport à l'ère
préindustrielle c'est à dire que là
toute la bande équatoriale va se
retrouver dans un climat ça a rien là où
il y aura énormément de monde compte
tenu des évolutions démographiques
qu'est ce qu'ils vont devenir ces gens
là si vous avez une afrique qui se meurt
du réchauffement climatique parce
qu'elle le prend de plein fouet
ça va encore accentuer le vieillissement
mondiale de la population
et puis par ailleurs vous aurez des
technologies qui vont tout changer
qui vont changer la donne l'intelligence
artificielle permet de permettra et la
robotique aussi permettront d'augmenter
énormément la productivité des économies
et pour duke pour le dire simplement
moins on aura de travailleurs d'hier est
humain biologique
plus on aura de moyens technologiques de
les remplacer par des travailleurs
mécaniques automatisés ce qui va poser
d'autres problèmes de réagencement de la
société en gros ce que je veux dire
c'est que cette question du
vieillissement il faut pas la pensée de
manière isolée dans un monde qui ne va
pas bouger il faut essayer de la
réfléchir et pourquoi pas même de la
prendre comme une occasion une chance
dans le cadre plus global d'un monde qui
va être totalement bouleversée dans les
décennies à venir
merci à beaucoup antoine loiseau d'avoir
été parmi nous dans cette émission je
rappelle que vous êtes essayé
c'est que votre ouvrage permis de
procurer est un retrouverez aux éditions
albin michel merci olivier c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
s'agit que nos précédentes émissions
sont à découvrir sur notre site internet
à l'adresse rt france pour tv et olivier
on se quitte avec le mot de la fin
écoutez vous pouvez éteindre vos
ordinateurs et fait des enfants quand
même